Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Forschergeist, dem Podcast des Stifterverbands für die deutsche Wissenschaft. Mein Name ist wie immer Tim Pritlove und das ist die 18. Ausgabe und die dritte, die jetzt hier in Reihe aus England produziert worden sein wird. Und diesmal hat mich der Weg nach Oxford geführt, weil ich hier einmal ein Thema aufgreifen wollte, was wir so in der Form noch nicht hatten. Das berührt auch die verschiedensten Bereiche. Ich sage erst mal hallo, und zwar zu Max Roser. Hallo, schönen guten Tag.
Ja hallo, hallo Tim.
Wir müssen erst mal sagen, wo wir hier sind. Also wir sind nicht nur in Oxford, sondern wir sind an der University of Oxford. Die Stadt besteht ja im wesentlichen eigentlich aus dieser Universität hat man so den Eindruck.
Ja ist schon ein großer Teil.
Und ganz konkret ist das hier das Institute of New Economic Thinking.
Ganz genau ja.
Das wiederum nochmal zur, kannst du das mal erklären, zur Martin School gehört.
Ja die Struktur in Oxford ist oft so ein bisschen verschachtelt. Also unser Institut oder mein Institut heißt eigentlich Program for Economic Modelling und das ist im Institute for New Economic Thinking und das ist Teil von der Oxford Martin School. Aber um es nochmal komplizierter zu machen sind wir auch Teil vom Departement für Ökonomie. Und alles ist ineinander verschachtelt und komplex. Und dann gibt es diese ganze College Struktur noch in Oxford, die nochmal da drüber liegt. So jeder ist ein Teil von einem Institute, ein Teil von der Fakultät und ein Teil von einem College. Und in der Schnittmenge irgendwo ist man dann zu Hause.
Das heißt man verbringt jetzt erst mal einen großen Teil damit, diese Struktur überhaupt zu verstehen.
Ich bin jetzt drei Jahre hier und kenne mich immer noch nicht aus.
Ja du bist jetzt hier glaube ich offiziell als Research Officer geführt.
Ja genau.
Sozusagen einen militärischen Rang.
Ganz genau.
Ich passe auf, dass da kein Ärger gemacht wird. Der Titel Research Officer kommt mir auch ein bisschen fremd immer noch vor. Aber die haben hier oft ein bisschen traditionelle Bezeichnungen für die einzelnen Jobs an der Uni. Letztlich bin ich ein Postdoc. Habe letztes Jahr mein Doktorat abgeschlossen und jetzt bin ich in der Stufe, die dann danach folgt. Die heißt meistens Postdoc, hier nennen sie mich Research Officer.
Was muss man darunter verstehen?
Wie ist denn die akademische Laufbahn bei dir so verlaufen? Also womit hat denn das angefangen? Es gab glaube ich am Anfang ein Studium der Philosophie oder so?
Ja das stimmt. Ich habe immer Philosophie studiert und das war lange die einzige Konstante und nebenbei habe ich andere Sachen gemacht. Ich habe einen Bachelor gemacht. Zum Großteil in Innsbruck in Österreich. In Philosophie einen Bachelor und dann habe ich Geowissenschaften studiert. Und dann bin ich vom Bachelor zum Master bin ich von Geowissenschaften auf Volkswirtschaft gewechselt und habe dann einen Master in Ökonomie gemacht und dann letztlich promoviert und die Promotion hatte Einkommensungleichheit, die Verteilung von Einkommen, die Verteilung von Vermögen auch ein Teil zum Thema. Und das Thema hat mich dann letztlich hier nach Oxford gebracht.
Philosophie, Geowissenschaften und Ökonomie. Passt das irgendwie zusammen oder waren das jetzt einfach unterschiedliche Interessen, die erst mal gar nichts miteinander zu tun hatten und man konnte sich dann entscheiden oder wie muss man das verstehen?
Es gibt schon Überschneidungen, bei denen das thematisch Sinn macht. Das Thema was ich gerade angesprochen habe, Einkommensverteilung, hat zu einem Großteil das Thema Gerechtigkeit im Hintergrund und da ist es ein Thema, was sowohl in der Philosophie natürlich als auch in der Ökonomie angelegt ist. Die Ökonomie, wie viele andere Wissenschaften, kommt aus der Philosophie. Die großen grundlegenden Texte sind geschrieben von Leuten wie Adam Smith zum einen oder Marx zum anderen. Leute, die sich sowohl in Philosophie als auch in Ökonomie auskennen. Und es gibt auch heute noch Ökonomen, die sehr stark in beiden Disziplinen verwurzelt sind. Das ist das eine und zum anderen ist glaube ich mein Interesse vorher schon immer irgendwie ein bisschen zwischen Sozialwissenschaften und zu verstehen von der Welt im großen gegangen. Und zum anderen hatte ich immer ein starkes mathematisches Interesse.
Mein ursprünglicher Plan war irgendwann mal, Physik zu studieren und sehr viel mathematischer unterwegs zu sein. Und dann hatte ich Geowissenschaften ausgewählt, weil ich gedacht habe, das ist vielleicht so ein Mittelweg zwischen einer Naturwissenschaft, die mathelastig ist und einem Blick auf die Welt, wie sie entstanden ist und wie sie heute ausschaut im Großen. Und von Volkswirtschaft wusste ich damals nichts, auch weil Volkswirtschaft kein großes Thema in der Schule in Deutschland ist. Aber letztlich ist Volkswirtschaft genau das was gesucht habe. Ein Fach, was stark in der Mathematik verwurzelt ist, aber thematisch sich anschaut, wie die Welt sich verändert und wie die Welt zu dem geworden ist, wie sie heute ist.
Und soziale Fragen aufwirft.
Genau ja. Also vielleicht, ich meine das ist immer das Ding, im Rückblick versucht man dann, da irgendeinen Weg zu erkennen in dem, wo man dann gelandet ist. Aber im Moment ist es ungefähr der Blick, den ich mir da zurecht lege.
Ja manchmal versteht man das auch erst zehn Jahre später, was man damit eigentlich gewollt hat. Weil es einen halt irgendwie gerufen hat. Und ich stelle eigentlich auch immer wieder fest, dass gerade Leute, die sehr divers unterwegs gewesen sind so in den Orientierungsjahren dann am Ende auf so eine ganz merkwürdige Art und Weise halt das alles irgendwie kombinieren in einer Art und Weise, wie man das so eben sich vorher hätte gar nicht ausdenken oder geschweige denn planen können.
Ja.
Wie kam es dann zu dem Weg nach England, nach Oxford?
Nach England bin ich gekommen, wegen dem Thema Einkommensverteilung. Das war das große Forschungsprojekt und ist immer noch mein Hauptforschungsthema. Und hier in Oxford gibt es einen Wissenschaftler der heißt Tony Atkinson und der ist der „Pate“ im Hintergrund von was es in Einkommens- und Armutsforschung in den letzten 4-5 Jahrzehnten wirklich gibt. Der ist jetzt gerade 70 letztes Jahr geworden. Und seit den 60ern veröffentlicht er und forscht er zu Armut und Einkommensverteilung. Und mit Tony war ich dann in Kontakt und bin dann nach Oxford gekommen, um mit ihm hier zu arbeiten.
Also das war dann einfach eine Einladung sozusagen, die sich da ergeben hat oder eine Bewerbung?
Ja es war eine thematische Nähe, die Sinn gemacht hat, dann nach Oxford zu kommen und hier weiter zu forschen.
Und war das dann einfach, hier anzudocken?
Forschungsmäßig glaube ich schon. Kulturell ist es sehr anders. England kommt mir immer noch ein bisschen fremd vor. Auch wenn es jetzt schon ein paar Jahre sind. Und Oxford, die Uni ist einfach schon ein bisschen seltsam, im Vergleich zu den Unis, die ich vorher gekannt habe. Ich war in Wien und in Innsbruck vorher und kurz vorher war ich in Rio de Janeiro, bevor ich nach Oxford gekommen sind. Und dass sind alles so ein bisschen die moderneren Unis, die von der Struktur sehr viel größer aufgebaut sind und sehr viel zentraler aufgebaut sind. Wir haben es am Anfang schon von dem Thema gehabt, von dem Institut im Institut und den Links zu den Colleges. Diese ganze Welt ist schon ein bisschen fremd hier. Und viele Dinge sind ein bisschen seltsam an der Universität und die Erklärung ist dann meistens, dass es irgendwann im 12. Jahrhundert so entschieden worden ist, dass es so läuft. Oxford ist in mancherlei Hinsicht so vom Formalen außenrum ist es ein sehr traditioneller Ort.
Ich hatte ja hier im letzten Gespräch im Forschergeist mit Ulinka Rublack gesprochen, die Professorin für frühzeitliche Historienforschung ist in Cambridge und die halt meinte ja, das wäre halt alles anders gewachsen. Auch das Elitenmodell mit all seinen Probleme hätte dann wiederum natürlich für die Lehre und Forschung den Vorteil, dass alles eben auch sehr viel überschaubarer ist und man eigentlich sehr gut Bedingungen findet für die Forschertätigkeit. Das ist hier auch wahrscheinlich nicht sehr viel anders oder?
Das stimmt schon. Die Bedingungen, hier zu arbeiten, sind wirklich wirklich gut. Zum einen weil man schon viel Freiheit hier hat und zum anderen auch, weil ... also in der Forschung hat man wirklich sehr viel Freiheit und zum anderen auch, weil man gute Kollegen hat, die in einer relativ kleinen Stadt schnell erreichbar sind und das netzwerk das hilft schon sehr. Das stimmt.
Es ging also um die Einkommensungleichheit weltweit sozusagen?
Ja weltweit, es sind zwei verschiedene Themen ein bisschen. Es gibt Forschung dazu, wie die Einkommen in der gesamten Welt verteilt sind, von den ärmsten Haushalten bis zu den reichsten Haushalten auf dem gesamten Planeten. Und dann gibt es, was im Moment in der Debatte vielleicht das größere Thema ist, ist die Einkommensverteilung innerhalb von einzelnen Ländern. Und das ist mehr das Thema mit dem ich mich beschäftige und wir machen Forschung zu der Verteilung von Einkommen vor allen Dingen in reicheren Ländern. In Europa, Nordamerika, Japan, Australien und den OLC-Ländern insgesamt.
Ist das hier ein zentrales Thema?
Ja, also die eine Gruppe, an der ich hier angeschlossen bin, die kümmert sich quasi nur um die Verteilung von Einkommen und Vermögen.
Ist das ... also ich frag mich jetzt ... okay wir sind ja hier am Institute of New Economic Thinking. Sollten wir vielleicht auch nochmal ein bisschen drüber reden. Was macht jetzt das aus, dass das Interesse an dem Thema so groß ist? Also gibt es viel Nachfrage, ist das generell im ökonomischen Wissenschaftsbereich ein vieldiskutiertes Thema, ist das nur hier ein Thema?
Das hat sich sehr stark gewandelt über die letzten Jahre. Die Einkommensverteilung war kein großes Thema in der Zeit, in der die moderne Ökonomie geschrieben worden ist. Im 20. Jahrhundert war das in den 50er, 60er, 70er Jahren war die Einkommensverteilung kein großes Thema. Zum einen deshalb, weil die Einkommensverteilung über die erste Hälfte vom 20. Jahrhundert sehr stark gefallen ist. Die Armen haben schnelleres Einkommenswachstum erlebt als die Reichen. Und das war der Fall in Deutschland, in England, in den USA, in quasi allen reichen Ländern ist die Einkommensschere stark zusammengegangen über die ersten 50 Jahre vom 20. Jahrhundert, vor allen Dingen über die Zeit vom 2. Weltkrieg. Und in den 60er/70er Jahren war die Einkommensungleichheit auf konstant historisch niedrigem Niveau. Und dann haben wir über die letzten drei Jahrzehnte, die 80er, 90er und 2000er haben wir sehr unterschiedliche Trends in verschiedenen Ländern.
In manchen Ländern steigt die Einkommmensungleichheit sehr stark, vor allen Dingen in den USA, wo Einkommen für die ärmsten 50-60% von der Bevölkerung fast stagnieren oder nur sehr gering zuwachsen und das obere Drittel starke Einkommenszuwächse hat. Und die Einkommen sich dort eben auseinander entwickeln. Und in anderen Ländern passiert das nicht so sehr oder auch gar nicht. Niederlande, Japan sind Länder, in denen die Einkommensungleichheit nicht zunimmt oder im Vergleich sehr viel weniger zunimmt. Also jetzt haben wir sehr unterschiedliche Entwicklungen, aber eben vor allen Dingen auch, weil die Einkommensungleichheit in den USA so stark zunimmt. Hier in England gab es einen großen Sprung der Zunahme der Ungleichheit in den 80er Jahren unter der Regierung von Thatcher. Und weil die Einkommensungleichheit zunimmt ist es auch wieder ein sehr viel stärkeres Thema und jetzt in den letzten 10 Jahren oder ist es auch in der Ökonomie wieder ein sehr zentrales Thema geworden.
Dieser große Überraschungserfolg von Thomas Pikettys Buch im letzten/vorletzten Jahr im Französischen, hat das Thema wirklich sehr stark zurückgebracht in den wissenschaftlichen Diskurs auch.
Weil das so sein Kernthema sogar war. Wie hieß das Buch noch gleich? Das war doch das mit der tollen Formel oder?
Genau, auf deutsch weiß ich gar nicht. Das heißt Capitals.
Kapital im 21. Jahrhundert ist wohl der deutsche Titel. Genau. 1:1 Übersetzung aus dem Französischen genau. Im Englischen einfach nur Capital in the 21. Century.
Ganz genau. Und Thomas Picketi hat es vor allen Dingen ermöglicht, dass wir so eine Langzeitperspektive auf die Entwicklung von Ungleichheit bekommen haben, was uns vorher nicht wirklich möglich war. Es gibt quasi zwei Möglichkeiten, über die Einkommensungleichheit was zu wissen. Das eine ist, dass man Umfragen macht und die Leute fragt, wie ihr Einkommen ausschaut. Und diese Umfragen reichen nicht weit zurück, sondern vielleicht bestenfalls in die 70er Jahre und dann vielleicht für einzelne Städte oder für einzelne Industriesektoren ein bisschen weiter zurück. Und die andere Möglichkeit, die Picketi wieder aufgegriffen hat, ist die Einkommenssteuerdaten zu nutzen. Und dann kann man soweit zurückgehen, wie Einkommenssteuer erhoben worden ist, in unterschiedlichen Ländern und das ist meistens in den ersten paar Jahrzehnten im 20. Jahrhundert erhoben worden oder seitdem wird das erhoben.
Also haben wir jetzt plötzlich eine Perspektive über 100 Jahre oder manchmal sogar ein bisschen länger als 100 Jahre und können diese langfristige Entwicklung, die ich am Anfang so ein bisschen skizziert habe, nachverfolgen.
Das Buch beschäftigt sich auch global mit dem Phänomen, jetzt nicht nur in Frankreich.
Genau. Die Daten die werden hier am Institut zusammengetragen. Hier gibt es die World Top Incomes Database und ich weiß nicht genau, das werden wahrscheinlich so ungefähr 30 Länder sein, für die wir jetzt Daten haben. Das sind die meisten europäischen Länder, dafür sind Daten da. Für die USA. Für ein paar afrikanische Länder gibt es ein paar Daten. Aber mehr und mehr Forscher schauen sich neue Länder an. Indien ist jetzt gerade neu dazu gekommen. Mauritius ist dazu. An Brasilien wird gerade gearbeitet und dann versucht man, eine Perspektive für jedes einzelne Land zu bekommen.
Wer hat denn Interesse daran? Also es scheint ja ein Interesse zu geben. Ist das jetzt ein rein akademisches Interesse? Gibt es da Schnittstellen zur Wirtschaft, Schnittstellen zur Politik? Wird das explizit nachgefragt oder bietet man sich nur der Öffentlichkeit an, aber sie antwortet nicht? Wie muss man sich das vorstellen, wie diese Forschung aufgenommen wir und unterstützt wird?
Das ist immer ein bisschen schwierig, das zu beurteilen, wenn man so mittendrin ist. Dann fehlt einem vielleicht der Blick von außen ein bisschen. Aber mir kommt vor, dass diese Forschung zur Einkommensverteilung schon sehr stark aufgenommen worden ist auch in der Öffentlichkeit. Wenn an die USA denkt, an die Proteste an der Wall Street, die Occupy Wall Street Proteste. Die hatten den Slogan, we are the 99%, der bis heute Mainstream in der Kultur von den USA ist über die letzten Jahre. Und der Slogan kommt direkt aus dieser Forschung, die vor allen Dingen die Top 1%, also die 1%, die das größte Einkommen in der Gesellschaft haben, rausgesucht hat. Und das lässt sich direkt zurückverfolgen auf die Forschung von Piketty und von einem Kollegen von ihm, der heißt Emmannuel Saez. Tony Atkinson, Facundo Alvaredo. Es gibt ein paar Forscher, die da sehr viel Arbeit in den letzten Jahren gemacht haben.
Und die Arbeit auch tatsächlich angekommen ist auf der Straße, wenn man so will, aber auch in der Politik. Der internationale Währungsfond hat Einkommmensungleichheit zu einem großen Thema gemacht. Die Weltbank veröffentlicht jetzt Daten, nicht nur zum Anstieg vom Durchschnittseinkommen, sondern auch zum Einkommen der unteren 40%, so dass man einen Blick darauf bekommt, ob das Wachstum tatsächlich alle mitnimmt oder ob das Wachstum sich nur auf eine kleine Schicht in der reichen Bevölkerung bezieht oder ob alle Boote gelüftet werden.
Kann man das so werten als ein wiedererstarktes oder überhaupt erst mal erstarktes Interesse an empirischen Daten überhaupt oder nur in diesem Fall? Also ist das irgendwie ein neues Phänomen, das man so stark datenlastig, so stark empirisch forscht oder hat es das schon irgendwie immer gegeben und jetzt ist es rein zufällig nur dieser Datenbereich, der jetzt in den Fokus gerückt wird?
Nein ich denke, das hat sich stark geändert. In der Ökonomie und in der Sozialwissenschaft insgesamt. Vor 50 Jahren hatten die Kollegen einfach weniger Daten zur Verfügung, da war man froh, wenn man irgendwie ein bisschen Daten zum, wenn man irgendwie was zum Bruttoinlandsprodukt sagen konnte oder vielleicht irgendwie was zu den Löhnen in einer Stadt, in einem Industriesektor. Und das hat sich dramatisch geändert über die letzten 50 Jahre, dass sehr viel mehr Wert gelegt wird, gute empirische Daten zu sammeln und die dann auch in der Wissenschaft zu nutzen. Ich denke aus meiner Perspektive ist es immer noch zu wenig. Und die Ökonomie ist immer noch sehr sehr theorielastig. Aber wenn man es vergleicht mit dem, wo die Wissenschaft vor ein paar Jahrzehnten war, dann hat sich das dramatisch in die empirische Richtung entwickelt.
Ich meine, es ist ja eigentlich naheliegend, wenn man sich anschaut, wie sich die gesamte wirtschaftliche Entwicklung an sich und überhaupt eigentlich die gesamte Gesellschaft in zunehmenden Maße digitalisiert. Der ganze wirtschaftliche Flow ja schon quasi durch Computer abgebildet wird beziehungsweise an der Börse nahezu dort komplett darin stattfindet, dann ist es ja eigentlich jetzt auch absehbar, dass man sehr viel mehr Daten auch überhaupt erst mal generiert und es jetzt eigentlich an der Zeit ist für die Wissenschaft, sich dieser Daten auch anzunehmen, aber das selbst scheint ein neuer Trend zu sein, da geht sozusagen ein Ruck durch die wissenschaftliche Szene.
Ich meine, das ist was was die Leute immer als BigData bezeichnen und ich denke, da ist schon was neues dabei, eben die Tatsache wie du sagst, dass die Daten sozusagen nicht mit der Absicht gesammelt werden, dass wir jetzt Daten erheben, sondern dass die Daten als Beiprodukt entstehen in der wirtschaftlichen Aktivität. Vielleicht an der Börse, aber vielleicht auch wenn wir die Daten haben, die Twitter nebenbei sammelt und die wir dann uns anschauen können für empirische Arbeiten. Und das ist die eine Sache, die Generierung von Daten, die du angesprochen hast, aber die andere Möglichkeit mit Computertechnik ist die Analyse von Daten. Wenn viele von diesen statistischen, ökonometrischen Methoden sind rechenaufwändig und Dinge, die wir heute mit einem Knopfdruck analysieren können, die hätten Wochen oder Monate gedauert für einen Forscher, der das in den 60er oder 70er Jahren gemacht hat. Also beides ist einfacher geworden, die Daten zu bekommen und die Daten dann auch zu analysieren.
Aber ist das mehr so eine Tätigkeit, dass man überhaupt erst mal losgehen muss und sie einsammeln muss oder liegen die Daten eigentlich gar nicht in der Form vor, wie man sie braucht?
Da gibt es beide Fälle. Es gibt natürlich große Institutionen, die die Daten sehr gut verfügbar machen. Zum Beispiel die Weltbank hat jetzt die Daten alle unter sehr freien Lizenzen herausgegeben und ist da wirklich stark involviert in der OpenData-Bewegung. Und dann liegen die Daten einfach fertig vor für die Analyse. Bei anderen Sachen muss man die Daten eben selbst erheben. Zum Beispiel die Forschung von Picketi, die wir vorhin angesprochen haben, das ist ein Beispiel, wo die Leute in die Archive gehen müssen vom Finanzministerium und die Einkommenssteuerzahlen von 1924 raus suchen müssen und dann aus den Zahlen versuchen müssen, zu schätzen, wie die Einkommen in der Gesellschaft damals verteilt waren.
Ja.
Dann ist die Datenerstellung quasi die Hauptarbeit.
Wie gesichert sind so diese Datenerhebungsmethoden? Also wie viel Vertrauen kann man sozusagen dieser Datengewinnung schenken? Ich meine, es ist ja auch an sich schon mal für den wissenschaftlichen Prozess sehr wichtig, dass man jetzt nicht nur sagt, naja ich habe da jetzt mal ein paar Blätter fotokopiert und paar Zahlen abgeschrieben, man muss ja dann in irgendeiner Form auch belegen können, nachweisen können, dass die Zahlen, die man da gewonnen hat auch wirklich Aussagekraft haben und dass es nicht noch andere Zahlen gibt, mit denen man sie noch hätte korrelieren müssen, bevor man anfängt, ihnen zu glauben.
Klar ich mein das ist das Problem, was insgsamt in der Wissenschaft zentral ist, dass man die Sachen transparent darstellen muss, woher die Daten stammen und dass man das seinen Kollegen quasi ermöglichen muss, so dass man seine Kollegen dazu bringen sollte, dass sie die Daten versuchen, zu replizieren und zu schauen, ob die Ergebnisse darin robust sind. Und es stimmt aber auch sicher, dass diese Daten mit einer großen Unsicherheit behaftet sind und diese Unsicherheit ist, vielleicht sollten wir eine bessere Arbeit machen und diese Unsicherheit auch kommunizieren. Es stimmt aber nicht nur für historische Daten, es stimmt auch für die gegenwärtigen Daten, die heute …
Alle Daten eigentlich.
Ja die wir heute in der Zeitung diskutieren. Wenn die neuen Wachstumszahlen für das letzte Quartal rauskommen. Das Quartal ist gerade erst abgeschlossen, dann kommen auch diese Zahlen mit einer großen Unsicherheit daher. Und in der Revision, die dann zwei Jahre später vorliegt, können die Zahlen ja ganz anders ausschauen. Zum Beispiel in der Finanzkrise gab es noch Zahlen für Quartale, in denen die Wirtschaft schon geschrumpft ist, die aber zum damaligen Zeitpunkt noch nicht bekannt waren und erst in der Revision haben wir erkannt, dass die Wirtschaft schon geschrumpft ist und nicht wie wir damals angenommen haben noch gewachsen ist. Also ich denke, das ist ein bisschen auch eine Kritik von mir, dass ich denke, wir legen zu viel Wert auf diese sehr sehr aktuellen Daten und diskutieren, ob das 0,1% Wachstum überraschend jetzt ist oder ob das eine Enttäuschung ist, dass die Wirtschaft nur 0,8 und nicht 0,9% gewachsen ist. Da ist die gleiche Unsicherheit da bei den Daten.
Ich denke, wir haben ja auch gerade so eine generelle Problematik speziell in Europa, in gewisser Hinsicht halt auch weltweit. Also das Vertrauen gegenüber dem Wirtschaftssystem betrifft die Griechenlandkrise, gerade jetzt hier in den letzten Monaten hat das denke ich sehr lebendig gezeigt, wie dort die Meinungen aufeinander treffen, aber wie sich halt auch jetzt starke politische Gegenbewegungen auch bilden, wie man das mit Syriza in Griechenland gesehen hat, europaweit gibt es auch so einen linken Gegentrend, der eben versucht, so ein bisschen dem kapitalistischen Status quo so ein wenig den Spiegel vorzuhalten. Wo ja dann auch die Systemfrage gestellt wird. Funktioniert unser System eigentlich? Ist diese Art und Weise, wie wir mit Schulden, mit Etats, mit Vertrauen von Märkten, der Kraft der Börsen und Investoren etc. umgehen, ist das überhaupt die richtige Basis für uns?
Und ich denke, es ist hier auch an der Wirtschaftswissenschaft, dort neue Anhaltspunkte und Leitlinien zu geben. Ich denke, das war auch so ein bisschen eine der Auswirkungen von Picketis Buch, eine Debatte in diese Richtung, die dadurch unter anderem auch ausgelöst wurde.
Ja. Ich denke die Debatte die ist richtig und Griechenland und auch in den USA geben Anlass zu der Debatte. Das ist die Frage, wie weit man die Systemfrage stellt. Ich denke, wir können das gegenwärtige System stark verbessern und Dinge die nicht funktionieren korrigieren. Ich denke, insgesamt ist die wirtschaftliche Entwicklung global gesehen immer noch extrem gut oder vielleicht besser denn je. Die Einkommen in den ärmsten Ländern auf der Welt steigen rasant. Südostasien hat eine gewaltige Entwicklung durchgemacht über die letzten 20 Jahre und die Lebensbedingungen von den Menschen dort extrem verbessert.
Südamerika ist nach Jahrzehnten von Diktaturen und Experimenten in Hinsicht der Wirtschaftssysteme auch in viel besserer Verfassung. Und über die letzten 15 Jahre oder vielleicht sogar 20 Jahre haben wir auch eine positive Entwicklung in großen Teilen von Afrika, die jetzt großes Wirtschaftswachstum erleben. Und ich denke, das ist eine Entwicklung, die vielleicht nicht so sehr in den Medien aufgegriffen wird, und wir haben einen sehr starken Fokus auf die negativen Entwicklungen. Aber ich denke, diese positiven Entwicklungen, die tatsächlich extrem wichtig sind für die Weltbevölkerung und unsere gegenwärtige Welt, die sollten wir auch nicht aus dem Auge verlieren.
Ja jetzt kommen wir gleich auch noch auf das Spezialprojekt von dir zu sprechen. Ich wollte nochmal kurz vorher hier die Selbstbeschreibung des Instituts nochmal kurz aufgreifen. Also dieses New Thinking, vielleicht überhöhe ich das jetzt auch so ein bisschen, aber dieses Neudenken von Wirtschaft, wenn man sich das hier schon in den Titel setzt, in welcher Form findet das statt? Also es scheint ja auch so ein bisschen Trend zu sein. Auch der Stifterverband hat ja eine entsprechende Konferenzreihe gestartet vor zwei Jahren, wo einfach diese Debatte eröffnet wird, um sozusagen das Selbstverständnis von Ökonomie, das Selbstverständnis der bisher akzeptierten Regeln und eben auch Maßstäbe. Was sind die Parameter, die für uns wichtig sind? Ist es irgendwie das Wachstum, ist das Glaube an Wachstum, ist das sozusagen auch das Ziel, für das die Politik arbeiten muss? Also wie wird das hier am Institut gesehen, was ist hier das Neue?
Ich muss sagen, ich bin nicht immer ganz so glücklich mit dem Namen New Economic Thinking, weil ich denke, die Wissenschaft, jede Disziplin, auch die Ökonomie teilt sich in viele Untergruppen auf und da gibt es immer Leute, die sehr neues machen und dann schreiben sie sich nicht unbedingt so diesen Titel auf die Fahne. Dass das Institut sich da selbst so rausnimmt mit diesem New Economic Thinking finde ich vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben. Aber in mancher Hinsicht denke ich stimmt es auch, dass Sachen in eine neue Entwicklung gehen. Ein großer Punkt ist der, den wir schon angesprochen haben, dass die Forschung hier sehr viel empirischer ist als in vielen anderen Gruppen. Ein anderer Punkt ist, dass es sehr stark von der Finanzkrise motiviert ist, von den Gründern vom Institut. Und dass die Finanzkrise, nicht so sehr bei mir, aber bei anderen, hier am Institut im Vordergrund steht.
Wann ist denn das gegründet worden das Institut? Wie neu ist das?
Die haben dann relativ bald nach der Krise 2007/2008 angefangen, darüber zu diskutieren und dann ist das Hauptinstitut ist in New York, obwohl das hier in Oxford glaube ich mittlerweile das größte Institut ist, aber es gibt mehrere, die zu diesem Institut von New Economic Thinking – INET ist die Abkürzung - dazu gehören.
Okay. Also ist das im Prinzip auch schon direkt so ein Kind dieser Infragestellung.
Ja. Das stimmt wohl.
Ja kommen wir mal zu dem anderen Projekt, was du glaube ich unabhängig jetzt hier von der Arbeit hier eigentlich gestartet hast. Das ist eigentlich eher so ein privates Ding gewesen.
Ja das stimmt.
Heißt Our World in Data. Ourworldindata.org und weiß nicht, vielleicht beschreibst du es mal selber. Das ist eine Webseite, die Daten zusammenträgt empirisch.
Genau.
Das ist eine Webpublikation, die ich vor vier Jahren gestartet habe und die Idee dort ist, die ganzen empirischen Daten, die wir haben, zusammenzutragen, so dass der Leser im Internet einen Überblick hat, wie sich verschiedene Aspekte, die wichtig sind für unser Leben, langfristig entwickelt haben. Wie hat sich die Armut entwickelt in der Welt? Wie hat sich die Armut in einzelnen Ländern entwickelt? Wie hat sich Gewalt zwischen Menschen verändert? Wie haben sich Kriege verändert? Wie ist die Nahrungsversorgung heute im Vergleich zu früher? Wie haben sich politische Systeme verändert? Wie ist die Bildungssituation? Und da versuche ich, die Daten sowohl von internationalen Organisationen zu benutzen als auch die Daten oft von Wirtschaftshistoriker und Sozialhistorikern zu nehmen. Die Daten rekonstruieren und dann die Daten sammele ich auf dieser Webseite und visualisiere sie, so dass der Leser eine Idee hat, wie der langfristige Trend ausschaut.
Über?
Was ist früher? Wie weit muss man da zurückgehen?
Ich versuche, so weit zurück zu gehen, wie es möglich ist. Und das ist oft überraschend, wie gut quantitative Informationen auch sind, die sehr weit zurückliegen. Zum Beispiel ein Thema, wo man eine sehr langfristige Perspektive einnehmen kann, ist, Gewalt. Menschen haben auch schon im Mittelalter sich Sorgen über die Gewalt zwischen Menschen gemacht und aufgeschrieben, wie viele Mordfälle es gab in verschiedenen Regionen. Und dann gibt es Sozialhistoriker, die durch die ganzen alten Archive sich wühlen und versuchen, einen Überblick zu bekommen, wie die Mordrate ausgesehen hat im mittelalterlichen England oder in der Schweiz oder in Skandinavien und dann nachzeichnen, wie die Gewalt sich verändert hat über die letzten Jahrhunderte.
Das ist zum Beispiel ein Beispiel, da gibt es vielleicht Zeitreihen, die bis ins 14. Jahrhundert zurückreichen und man kann noch weiter zurückgehen. Es gibt auch Archäologen, die Grabstätten untersuchen und dann an den Skeletten untersuchen, auf welche Weise die Menschen gestorben sind.
Ja ich schaue hier gerade mal Homicides, darauf bezieht sich das wahrscheinlich gerade oder?
Das geht bis 1300 zurück.
Ganz genau.
Ist das nicht sehr gewagt?
Genau ja.
Die Daten sind überraschend gut. Das ist auch der Punkt bei dieser Publikation. Wenn du jetzt da diesen Graph anschaust, hast du direkt neben dran den Link zu der wissenschaftlichen Publikation. Ich denke die ist von Manuel Eisner, der in Cambridge ist, ein Schweizer Kriminologe. Und dort kannst du dir das ganze Paper durchlesen und mehr Informationen dazu finden, wie verlässlich diese Daten sind.  Und die Daten, die ich auf der Webseite habe, die zeigen nur Durchschnittswerte für glaube ich halbe Jahrhunderte. Und wenn du zu seiner Seite zu seinem Paper gehst, dann hast du für jedes Land auch die rohen Daten und kannst dir die direkt dort anschauen.
Das heißt diese eine Auswälzung bezieht sich tatsächlich auch nur auf eine einzige Studie?
In dem Fall sind es glaube ich zwei Sachen, die ich zusammengebracht habe. Ich habe dann Daten damit kombiniert von den vereinten Nationen. Aber die Daten, die Eisner verwendet, die sind wieder aggregiert aus verschiedenen länderspezifischen Studien. Und das ist auch das Thema, was wir vorhin schon angesprochen haben, die Daten haben eine Unsicherheit, aber in dem Fall ist denke ich die Unsicherheit sehr viel geringer, als der Trend über die Zeit. Heute in Westeuropa haben die meisten Länder so eine Mordrate von ungefähr einem Mord pro 100.000 Menschen pro Jahr. Im 13. Jahrhundert sind es zwischen 30 und 50 Morden pro 100.000 pro Jahr.
Italien bringt es auf 73 pro 100.000 im Jahre 1450.
Genau. Und dann ist diese Reduktion um den Faktor 50 ist sehr viel größer, als die Unsicherheit mit der die Daten behaftet sind.
Also ich denke, die Visualisierung jetzt in diesem Beispiel zumindest macht sehr klar, dass selbst wenn es da Ungenauigkeiten gibt, die Dimension in denen sich das bewegt, die werden relativ schnell klar. Ich meine, wenn man hier auf viele der Visualisierungen schaut hat man das Gefühl, eigentlich ist ja alles total super.
Ich denke, das ist auch ein Punkt bei der Sache, dass die Leistung wie wir die Welt verändert haben, ist in vielen Teilen wirklich bewundernswert. Während wenn wir jemandem in den 70ern erzählt hätten, wie die Welt im Jahr 2010 ausschaut, die hätten uns für die verrücktesten Optimisten und Wahnsinnigen gehalten.
Was zum Beispiel ist so unglaublich?
Wenn du zum Beispiel dir Asien anschaust und die Vorhersagen in den 70ern anschaust. Die Leute waren davon überzeugt, dass die Überbevölkerung in Asien zu gigantischen Hungersnöten führt, bei der Millionen von Menschen in Asien sterben würden. Und was passiert ist in den letzten vier Jahrzehnten ist genau das umgekehrte. Die Ernährungssituation in Asien hat sich extrem stark verbessert. Hungersnöte sind heute auf die Länder konzentriert, die von Diktatoren regiert werden wie Nordkorea. Und das ist sehr sehr anders, als das was wir vor 30-40 Jahren noch für möglich gehalten hätten. Also in vielen Teilen denke ich, ist es uns einfach nicht bewusst, wie dramatisch sich die Welt verbessert hat und die Lebensbedingungen sich verbessert haben.
Aber den Schluss daraus zu ziehen, dass wir uns dann zurücklehnen können und uns auf die Schulter klopfen können und nichts mehr machen brauchen, das ist denke ich genau der falsche Schluss. Ich denke der Punkt ist, die Anstrengung die wir tun, um die Welt besser zu ernähren zum Beispiel, die tragen tatsächlich Früchte und es macht Sinn, sich in der Welt zu engagieren und da weiter zu helfen, die vielen gravierenden Probleme, die es noch gibt, weiter zu lösen.
Also man könnte jetzt quasi hier den Eindruck bekommen, das ist so eine Optimismuskollektion. Was wollt ihr eigentlich ist doch alles total toll, weil alle Kurven zeigen irgendwie nach unten. Allerdings gibt es ja auch ein paar Kurven, die nach unten zeigen oder umgekehrt nach oben, je nachdem wie man das dann sieht, die dem ja auch entgegenwirken. Ich weiß nicht, ich habe das nur im Ansatz reingeschaut, aber es gibt ja auch verschiedene Aufstellungen zur Entwicklung der Umwelt. Also Bewaldung der Oberfläche etc. da sind ja jetzt die Entwicklungen nicht so positiv.
Genau. Also der Punkt ist nicht, dass es eine Kollektion von besonders optimistischen Daten ist, sondern der Punkt ist, dass man die Daten, die verfügbar sind, die besten Daten, die wir kennen, darzustellen und dann ist es tatsächlich der Fall, dass die meisten Entwicklungen sehr positiv sind. Bei Umweltthemen, die sind auch Teil von der Webpublikation, ist es nicht immer der Fall. Obwohl man da auch differenzieren muss. Zum Beispiel hast du jetzt Wald angesprochen, dieses Jahr jetzt gerade vielleicht vor 2-3 Monaten gab es eine große Publikation entweder in Science oder Nature, die gezeigt hat, dass zum ersten Mal die globale Waldfläche zunimmt. Und es ist sicher seit Jahrhunderten das erste Mal, die Waldrodung und Abholzung ist nichts neues, sondern geht soweit zurück, wie Menschen versuchen, das Land urbar zu machen und Landwirtschaft zu betreiben.
Und heute durch sehr viel produktivere Landwirtschaft ist es möglich, die Agrarflächen zu reduzieren und tatsächlich wieder Flächen zu bewalden. Also im Schnitt nimmt die Waldfläche wieder zu. Es ist natürlich auch richtig, dass die Waldfläche vor allen Dingen in den tropischen Regenwäldern immer noch schrumpfen und abgeholzt werden. Und der Fall ist auch weiterhin in Brasilien, auch wenn da der Trend rückläufig ist seit mehreren Jahren. Aber die Flächen in den reicheren Ländern, die Waldflächen dort zunehmen. Und auch vor allen Dingen in China stark zunehmen. Was ich auch nicht gewusst habe, bevor ich das Paper gelesen habe. Aber China macht große Aufforstungsprojekte anscheinend. Und das sorgt dafür, dass die Waldfläche wieder zunimmt.
Die Datenpunkte sind ja hier sehr breit angelegt, aber wir haben jetzt schon einiges angesprochen. Aber es gibt ja jetzt hier auch diverse Untersuchungen zu Technologie, Krieg und Frieden, aber auch so soziale Entwicklung, also politische Entwicklung in Ländern. Also zum Beispiel, fand ich sehr interessant, hier die Aufstellung, Number of Democracies. Wobei ich war ein bisschen überrascht, weil hier so unglaublich viele verschiedene Arten von Demokratien aufgestellt wurden. Wenn man so Tagesschau guckt, dann denkt man ja immer so, das wäre eine digitale Geschichte, entweder man hat eine Demokratie oder man hat keine. Was lässt sich hier ablesen?
Demokratie – sicher, das ist auch schwierig, so was komplexes wie die komplette politische Struktur von einem Land am Schluss in einer Zahl auszudrücken. Es gibt verschiedene Versuche, das zu tun. Und auf der Webseite verwende ich vor allen Dingen einen Index der heißt Polity, und da gibt es den Polity4, der Polity5 glaube ich kommt jetzt gerade raus – und die machen tatsächlich sehr detaillierte Studien für jedes Land und untersuchen, welche Rechte das Regierungsoberhaupt hat, wie die Wahlen dort ablaufen und du kannst ja für jedes einzelne Land dort die tatsächlichen Protokolle anschauen und das ist sehr transparent und du siehst, was die Grundlage für ihre Bewertung letztlich ist.
Und am Schluss aggregieren sie diese ganze Beurteilung von einem politischen System in mehreren Kennzeilen, die dann nochmal aggregiert werden können zu einer zentralen Kennzahl, die dann in dieser Abbildung dargestellt wird, die du dir jetzt anschaust. Und das ist dann ein Spektrum von einer total Autokratie, die glaube ich mit -10 bewertet wird dort bis zu einer totalen Demokratie, die mit +10 bewertet wird und den verschiedenen politischen Formen auf diesem Spektrum geben sie dann unterschiedliche Namen.
Ja da gibt es dann eine Anocracy. Was ist das denn?
Eine Anokratie ist deren Bezeichnung für ein politisches System, das eben auf diesem Spektrum liegt zwischen …
Also noch nicht so totale Diktatur, aber auch nicht so richtig frei.
Genau, was ja auch tatsächlich für viele Länder der Fall ist. Und du kannst dann auf den, es gibt da noch diese interaktiven Karten, auf denen ich die gleichen Daten dann visualisiere, da kannst du dir genau anschauen, welches Land zum Beispiel als Anokratie da bezeichnet wird.
Was ich mich jetzt so ein bisschen gefragt habe, als mir diese vielen verschiedenen Datenpunkte und Datenkategorien vor allem angeschaut habe, inwiefern sich so etwas dann noch miteinander in Verbindung setzen lässt. Also es sind jetzt alles sehr unterschiedliche Parameter, die aber natürlich auch irgendwie was miteinander zu tun haben. Also ich würde sagen, so was wie Versorgung und Gesundheit der Bevölkerung lässt sich sicherlich auch in Bezug setzen zu der Anzahl Kriege und der politischen Ordnung. Technologische Entwicklung spielt da genauso gut mit rein und dann wiederum der Zustand der Umwelt mag auch damit korreliert sein. Ist das etwas, was du dir vorstellen kannst, dass man das dann daraus dann mal machen könnte? Also es gibt ja hier auch interaktive Visualisierung, das sind ja jetzt nicht nur so einfach Plots, sondern man kann dann irgendwie rumklicken, so ein bisschen Zeitachsen verschieben und andere Sachen miteinander in Verbindung bringen, je nachdem wie die Auswertung so gemacht ist. Ist das eine Vision des Projekts, vielleicht mehr Korrelation noch herzubringen?
Ja und das ist auch tatsächlich in manchen. Das ist noch nicht überall umgesetzt, aber in vielen Abschnitten der Webpublikation ist es schon der Fall und es ist jeder Artikel, jedes Thema soll so behandelt werden, dass im ersten Teil die langfristige Entwicklung dargestellt wird. Wie haben sich Demokratien über die letzten 200 Jahre verändert? Welche Länder sind wann demokratisch geworden und wann sind sie wieder zurückgefallen? Und diese langfristige Perspektive soll im ersten Abschnitt dargestellt werden und im zweiten Abschnitt soll das dann in Verbindung gesetzt werden mit den anderen Themen, die auf der Webseite publiziert werden. Und es soll erklärt werden, was wissen wir darüber, warum Länder demokratisch werden? Zum Beispiel ein entscheidender Punkt da ist die Bildung. Und dann versuche ich die Forschung darzustellen, die empirische Forschung, die es zu der Frage der Demokratisierung gibt.
Und dann ein paar Visualsierungen auch daraus darzustellen. Zum Beispiel für die Demokratie habe ich eine Visualisierung gemacht, in der du so einen Scatter-Plot hast, bei der du eine Variable gegenüber einer anderen Variable darstellen kannst. Auf der X-Achse unten siehst du für jedes Land die Bildungssituation in den 1970ern und auf der Y-Achse als abhängige Variable sozusagen siehst du den Demokratisierungs-Index, den wir vorher besprochen haben und dann siehst du diese starke Korrelation, die dir anzeigt, dass die Länder, die eine stark gebildete Bevölkerung haben, mit größerer Wahrscheinlichkeit demokratisch sind und in dem Text der dazu neben der Abbildung zu finden ist, verlinke ich dann zu Studien, die über die reine Korrelation quasi hinausgehen und tatsächlich versuchen, einen kausalen Effekt zu untersuchen von Bildung auf Demokratie.
Welche Erkenntnisse haben sich denn jetzt so daraus ergeben, außer dieser es ist alles gar nicht so schlecht in der Zukunft oder in der Gegenwart.
Das ist nicht der Punkt. Der Punkt ist nicht, dass es nicht so schlecht ist. Es geht um die Richtung, wie die Welt sich verändert. Es geht nicht darum, zu sagen, dass wir keine Probleme mehr haben. In vielen Aspekten ist es optimistisch, weil die Dinge besser sind, als sie vor 10-20 oder 100 Jahren waren. Aber es ist nie die Aussage, dass es gut genug ist.
Nein, das wollte ich jetzt damit auch nicht unterstellen. Sondern eher nur die Frage, was für andere Erkenntnisse kann man denn daraus ziehen? Also bestätigt einen das jetzt im allgemeinen Trend, oder lassen sich hier auch sozusagen – also ich nehme jetzt mal das Beispiel mit Bildung und demokratischer Entwicklung nehmen, das legt ja sozusagen nahe, okay wenn wir mehr auf Bildung wert legen, dann führt es zu offeneren Gesellschaften.
Genau. Ich denke auch, das ist ein Punkt, dass wir kommunizieren können, was die Forschung darüber weiß, wie wir die Welt demokratischer, gerechter, reicher machen können. Und dass es uns zeigt, was uns diese Institutionen oder Technologien oft nutzen. Zum Beispiel bei der Demokratie, da gibt es vielleicht zwei Punkte. Eine wichtige Verbindung von der Demokratie ist hin zu Kriegen. Was auch ein Thema in der Publikation ist. Und es wird bezeichnet als die Theorie von demokratischem Frieden.
Und wir haben sowohl gute theoretische Modelle oder Überlegungen, als auch gute empirische Evidenz, dass demokratische Länder weniger oft oder weniger wahrscheinlich mit anderen demokratischen Ländern im Krieg stehen als autokratische Länder. Dass Demokratie in dieser Weise zu Frieden führt. Und vielleicht ein anderer Aspekt bei der Demokratie ist, dass wir wissen, dass in Demokratien es keine Hungersnöte gibt. Hungersnöte sind im 20. Jahrhundert/21. Jahrhundert nicht Probleme von der Nahrungsknappheit, sondern das sind Probleme von der Nahrungsverteilung. Und oft ist es in Ländern, in denen es Hungersnot gibt, oft ist es überraschend einfach, diese Hungersnot zu beenden oder wäre es überraschend einfach, diese Hungersnot zu beenden.
Zum Beispiel in den großen Hungersnöten in den 70ern und 80ern in Äthiopien, da hat es kleine Teile von Äthiopien betroffen, während andere Teile von Äthiopien gut mit Nahrung versorgt werden. Und es wäre einfach möglich gewesen, diese Nahrung dorthin zu transportieren, wo sie benötigt worden wäre. Aber in autokratischen Regierungen kommt es oft vor, dass die Regierung mehr damit beschäftigt ist, ihr eigenes Ansehen zu retten und versucht, die Berichte über die Hungersnot zu unterdrücken oder einfach ein völliges Desinteresse an dem Wohlergehen der Bevölkerung hat und dann die Nahrung nicht so umverteilt, wie es möglich gewesen wäre. Das gleiche gilt für Nordkorea in der großen letzten Hungersnot dort. Und dann gibt diese langfristige Perspektive und diese empirische Darstellung gibt einfach zwei gute Gründe, Frieden und keine Hungersnöte, die Demokratie so enthusiastisch zu verteidigen, wie sie es verdient.
Eigentlich alles ganz einfach.
Manche Dinge sind denke ich relativ einfach. Bei anderen Sachen wissen wir es nicht, aber wir müssen diese Aspekte da auch besser kommunizieren.
Ich meine, ich finde es ja interessant, dass ja hier im Prinzip so eine Art Schulbuch entsteht, was einem einfach mal eine Grundlage der politischen Gesamtzusammenhänge der Welt gibt. Aber die jetzt nicht einfach so eine dahingeschriebene Theorie sind, sondern die sich einfach ganz konkret an zusammengetragenen Zahlen teilweise über Jahrhunderte, manche Sachen sind ja auch nur ein paar Jahrzehnte überhaupt erfasst worden oder sind sagen wir mal Datenpunkte, die überhaupt erst seit ein paar Jahrzehnten relevant sind, so technologische Entwicklung etc. Ich weiß nicht, ob es irgendwas zum Thema Internet gibt, ich habe bisher noch nichts gesehen.
Da sind wir gerade dabei.
Aha okay, was wird da?
Ja da geht es nicht um ein paar Jahrhunderte zurück.
Verbreitung, Zugang, Internetzugang?
Genau. Und dann der Zugang zu Internet, die Verbreitung, wie viele Leute sind im Internet. Mit welcher Geschwindigkeit können die Leute im Internet auf das Internet zugreifen. Das ist ein großes Thema  ein. Wie ist die Infrastruktur, wie hat sich die entwickelt über die letzten Jahrzehnte. Und dann eben auch diese Fragen, was sind die Verbindungen zu anderen wichtigen Themen? Was ist die Verbindung zum Beispiel vom Internet zu politischem Protest. Ein Thema, was zumindest vor einigen Jahren noch groß in den Schlagzeilen war. Und da ein bisschen die empirischen Arbeiten zusammen zu tragen. Aber es ist noch nicht online. Wird in den nächsten Tagen oder Wochen kommen.
Also mit anderen Worten, das ist ein sehr lebendiges Projekt, was vor allem schon seit vier Jahren betrieben wird, aber noch in keiner Hinsicht ans Ende angekommen ist?
Naja vor vier Jahren habe ich angefangen, ein Buch zu schreiben. Und habe versucht, dafür einen empirischen Blick zu bekommen auf die Welt, weil ich das in dem Buch darstellen wollte und irgendwann habe ich dann realisiert, dass die Sache nicht mehr so gut zwischen zwei Buchdeckel passt und habe dann angefangen, die Sache im Internet gratis zur Verfügung zu stellen. Und die Seite an sich ist eigentlich erst seit einem Jahr online. Ich habe angefangen Daten zu sammeln vor vier Jahren. Ich habe angefangen, an der Webseite zu arbeiten, ich weiß nicht mehr genau. Vielleicht vor 2-2,5 Jahren so was. Aber die Seite ist erst seit Juni letzten Jahres online. Und ich hoffe, dass es noch lange weitergehen kann.
Es gibt noch viele viele Aspekte, die wir darstellen wollen und ich habe so eine Art offline Our World in Data auf meinem Computer mit den ganzen Daten, die ich über die Jahre gesammelt habe zu den verschiedenen Themen. Und die Offline-Datenbank umfasst, ich weiß nicht, vielleicht fünf mal mehr als das.
Also ist noch nicht mal alles im Netz. Da ist sozusagen noch viel Arbeit zu leisten.
Genau.
Muss man vielleicht nochmal kurz sagen. Also wenn du jetzt wir sagst, es ist ja nicht wirklich ein Projekt dieses Instituts, wo wir jetzt gerade hier sind. Oder ist es das mittlerweile auch?
Das hat sich geändert. Am Anfang war das mein Feierabendprojekt und ich habe als Hobby dran gearbeitet. In den letzten zwei Jahren habe  ich ein bisschen Freiheit bekommen während meiner Arbeit zur Einkommensungleichheit, dass ich das auf der Seite ein bisschen mitlaufen lassen habe. Und jetzt für diese Jahr 2015 habe ich ein kleines Funding bekommen von einer Stiftung in London und seit acht Wochen ungefähr ist ein Web-Developer mit an Bord und zwei Studenten hier von der Uni, die mir helfen, die Publikation zu schreiben.
Das heißt jetzt wird das eigentlich überhaupt erst mal auf eine technische Basis gestellt, weil du nicht von Haus aus nicht im Bereich Datenvisualisierung unterwegs bist?
Ja genau. Ich habe keinen Hintergrund in Informatik oder so und habe das so amateurmäßig nebenbei aufgebaut. Und jetzt hoffe ich, dass wir mit der Hilfe von einem kleinen Team da mehr machen können.
Kommen wir jetzt aber auch nochmal auf einen interessanten Punkt. Weil mir ist ja das Projekt auch so im Laufe des letzten Jahres so über den Weg gelaufen und ich fand das einfach so in seiner ganzen Ausrichtung und in dem absehbaren Umfang und dem Potenzial schnell klar geworden, dass ich das interessant finde. Und vor allem, weil es irgendwie, obwohl es eine wissenschaftliche Arbeit ist, eigentlich sehr anders rüberkommt, als man das gemeinhin von wissenschaftlichen Arbeiten so gewohnt ist. Also insbesondere jetzt natürlich auch die Verheiratung mit dem Web und die Art und Weise wie hier auch Öffentlichkeit geschaffen wird. Das ist ja nicht unbedingt immer so. Also hast du irgendwie das Gefühl, dass du viel wissenschaftliche Arbeit, den wissenschaftlichen Bereich auch irgendwie nicht so richtig verlässt.
Und jetzt haben wir ja schon gehört, dass hier eigentlich sehr viele, in diesem Konzert sehr viele einzelne Melodien hervortreten, die sehr wohl für unterschiedliche gesellschaftliche Strömungen sehr interessant sein können. Nur dass diese Kommunikation an der Stelle gar nicht da ist. Vielleicht mal selber noch mal ein bisschen beschreiben, wie für dich so der Weg mit diesem Projekt in die Öffentlichkeit war und welche Rolle das Netz dabei gespielt hat?
Ich denke, es ist fast schwieriger zu beantworten, warum man das nicht häufiger macht. Die Möglichkeiten, im Internet Sachen zu publizieren sind offensichtlich in vielerlei Weise oft viel abwechslungsreicher und besser denke ich als auf Papier. Und verschiedene Zeitungen zum Beispiel machen extrem gute Arbeit im Internet und nutzen die Möglichkeiten. In der Wissenschaft ist es leider oft so, dass die Technologie, mit der unsere Ergebnisse publiziert werden können, die hätte auch Gutenberg am Tag danach verwenden können. Wir schreiben vielleicht die wissenschaftlichen Veröffentlichungen und machen sie im Netz verfügbar, aber das sind immer noch DIN A4 Seiten, die wir dann aus dem PDF herunterladen und ausdrucken.
Und diese Menge an empirischen Daten die bietet sich im Internet einfach zur Veröffentlichung an, weil damit auch, ich meine vielleicht hilft es, wenn man konkreter wird, wir haben Daten zur Entwicklung der Einkommensungleichheit für 50 oder 80 Länder auf der Erde und wenn ich versuchen würde, einen Überblick zu geben über die Entwicklung der Einkommensungleichheit in einem Buch, dann müsste ich mir aus den 80 Ländern die fünf Länder raus suchen, die ich gerade am interessantesten finde und dann zeige ich eben Frankreich, USA, Deutschland, Schweden und Japan und alle anderen 75 Länder die halte ich dem Leser vor und er kann die Daten nicht sehen. Im Internet ist es kein Problem, die Daten für fünf Länder auszuwählen und standardmäßig anzuzeigen und per Fingerklick ist es für den Leser möglich, auch die Daten für Brasilien oder Südafrika oder Italien verfügbar zu machen. Also für die Arbeit ist das Internet extrem hilfreich.
Ist denn das bei our world in data so, dass die Daten selber auch alle herunterladbar sind?
In die Richtung wollen wir gehen. Das ist natürlich manchmal ein Problem mit Copyrights für die Daten. Aber für viele Daten ist es jetzt mittlerweile möglich ja. Zum Beispiel haben wir gerade einen neuen Artikel geschrieben mit meinen beiden Kollegen, die jetzt mit mir arbeiten, zu Selbstmorden. Wenn du den Suicide-Artikel anschaust auf der Seite, dann hast du die ganzen Daten von der Weltgesundheitsorganisation verfügbar.
Inwiefern also Copyright an was?
Für die Daten. Zum Beispiel manche von den Daten, die wir verwenden, sind von wissenschaftlichen Papern und dann möchten die Autoren nicht, dass die Daten im Internet verfügbar gemacht werden.
Warum?
Weil sich die ... ich meine, das ist schon verständlich in mancher Hinsicht. Ich habe oft schon Arbeit gemacht und habe sie danach wieder – nicht oft, aber ist schon vorgekommen, dass ich Arbeit gemach habe und danach konnte ich es nicht online zeigen, sondern musste dann die Daten von der interaktiven Grafik in eine statische Grafik umwandeln, weil die Autoren nicht wollten, dass die Daten herunterladbar sind. Manchmal denke ich ist es auch verständlich, oder ich denke, dass es verständlich ist, weil in manchen Forschungen ist es einfach die Arbeit von einem Jahr, dass die Daten verfügbar gemacht werden und dann hat der Forscher ein Interesse, dass er die Daten als erster auswertet und die Publikationen schreibt, die mit diesen Daten möglich sind.
Also vor ein paar Ausgaben habe ich ja hier mit Nikolaus Kriegesgrotte gesprochen, da ging es halt generell genau um diese Problematik des althergebrachten Veröffentlichens von Studien, der Problematik, dass eben immer noch sehr viel über Journale läuft, alles noch über sehr viel traditionelle Reputation läuft, und dass dadurch nicht nur die Veröffentlichung teilweise nennenswert verzögert wird. Also Datenstudienergebnisse sehr viel später überhaupt erst das Licht des Tages sehen, sondern auch überhaupt grundsätzlich nicht in demselben Maße digital verfügbar sind, nicht offen sind, nicht problemlos zitierbar sind, das sind ja genau solche Fragestellungen, die jetzt hier auch eine Rolle spielen. In dem Gespräch gab es auch ein starkes Plädoyer für einen Open-Science-Ansatz, also sozusagen überhaupt Daten besser, also Studien generell digital zu veröffentlichen, früh zu veröffentlichen und unter liberalen Lizenzen zu veröffentlichen.
Gibt es da nicht auch Gegenbeispiele? Also gab es hier auch Studien, die herangezogen wurden, wo das überhaupt gar kein Problem war, die von Vornherein so angelegt waren?
Die Resonanz im Großen ist sehr positiv. Wenn ich Autoren direkt anschreiben musste, dass die die Daten verfügbar machen, dann sind die meistens sehr freigiebig mit den Daten und machen sie öffentlich und denke ich haben auch daran Interesse,  weil sie dann wieder über die Webpublikation wieder …
Neue Aufmerksamkeit dafür bekommen?
Sind das denn jetzt ausschließlich Studien Dritter oder sind da auch eigene Studien mit drin? Eigene methodische Auswertungen?
Ganz genau.
Ich versuche schon, die wichtigen Publikationen in den verschiedenen Feldern darzustellen. Und naja gut, ich habe nicht immer die wichtigsten. Also sind es oft die Studien, die zentral für die Literatur sind und die Studien von anderen.
Okay, also im Prinzip ist das Projekt ja auch so eine Art best of.
Also man muss sich ja geradezu geehrt fühlen, wenn man hier vertreten ist?
Genau ja.
Ja.
Also vielleicht hat sich das noch nicht so rumgesprochen. Aber im Prinzip ist das ja sozusagen der Ansatz.
Das wäre ideal, wenn die Leute das so wahrnehmen würden.
Dass das quasi auch die Rolle eines naja Journals übernimmt in gewisser Hinsicht, weil es ja dadurch quasi auch Reputation hinzufügt für eine Studie.
Ja, in die Richtung würde ich es gerne entwickeln genau. Das funktioniert auch ganz gut mit Leuten hier von der Uni, dass Leute in Themen, in denen ich kein Experte bin, zum Beispiel Nahrungsversorgung hatten wir vorhin als Thema, da kenne ich mich nicht aus, dass ich da mit Leuten zusammenarbeiten kann von der Uni hier, die dann helfen, die relevanten Daten, die relevanten Publikationen zu finden und quasi so ein Skelett mit mir entwickeln für den Artikel. Und in die Richtung würde ich gern weiter gehen, dass tatsächlich die Experten von einzelnen Themen auch die Autoren oder Coautoren werden für die einzelnen …
Also sozusagen auch selber kuratorisch tätig werden innerhalb des Projektes.
Dass sich die einzelnen Kategorien quasi verselbstständigen und von anderen betreut werden.
Genau.
Genau, das wäre ideal.
Muss sich erst entwickeln. Jetzt bin ich ein Jahr dabei, in die Richtung würde ich gerne gehen.
Aber muss sich halt erst entwickeln.
Ich finde das einfach mal auch wert, das von der Seite auch zu denken, was das quasi für die wissenschaftliche Publikation bedeutet. Du hast gesagt, du hast Leute angesprochen für ihre Studien, die dann eben mehr oder weniger offen waren, Daten rauszurücken und die könnten darüber Feedback bekommen. Hat das stattgefunden? Also haben die, ist Rückmeldung sozusagen über die Publikation in our world in data an diese Leute zurückgekommen? Also gab es eine Rückmeldung der Leute aufgrund der Veröffentlichung?
Wo das auf jeden Fall funktioniert ist, ... ich meine oft ist diese Publikation, die ich mache, so ein bisschen eine Schnittstelle zwischen Wissenschaft und Medien und wenn Medien, Zeitungen oder Radio oder Fernsehen, was so die Themen aufgreifen, dann kommen sie oft zu mir und ich verweise sie dann zurück auf die Autoren, die die Daten oder das Paper tatsächlich geschrieben haben. Das passiert häufig ja.
Es gibt ja auch den Trend im Journalismus, noch ein sehr zartes Pflänzchen, aber ist auf jeden Fall sichtbar, was man so unter Datenjournalismus zusammenfasst. Teilweise gibt es ja auch schon etwas zukunftsorientiertere größere Zeitungen, New York Times ist glaube ich ein gutes Beispiel. Guardian sicherlich auch, es gibt auch andere Beispiele in Deutschland, wo mal jemand gesagt hat, es reicht nicht nur immer nur zu berichten, sondern wir müssen im Prinzip selber mit diesen Daten arbeiten. Wir sind auch als Journalisten gezwungen, genauso handfeste, zählbare, nachweisbare Daten zusammenzutragen und können dann auch über eigene Visualisierung im Prinzip unseren Punkt sehr viel besser rüberbringen. Bzw. die Recherche auch in den Daten selber machen. Nicht nur Leute befragen über ihre Interpretation, sondern diese Interpretation im Prinzip neu aufzustellen, anhand von so einer Datenanalyse. Das sind dann wahrscheinlich dann auch so die Orte, wo solche Publikationen wie our world in data eigentlich wunderbar reinpasst.
Ja die haben das auch, jetzt zum Beispiel New York Times und Guardian, die haben das beide schon aufgenommen und dann weiter verwendet. Und eine andere Verbindung in die Richtung ist auch, das kriege ich mit über Social-Media oder E-Mail, dass Journalisten die Seite von mir verwenden, um Daten überhaupt zu finden. Also zum einen übernehmen sie die Grafiken, die da sind, zum anderen verwenden sie meine Datenbank als so eine Art Datenbank von Datenbanken und wenn sie dann Interesse haben an Daten zur Einkommensverteilung, dann finden sie auf meiner Seite eine Liste von den 12 oder 15 großen Datenbanken zu Einkommensverteilung und gehen dann dorthin und finden die Daten. Also ich versuche so ein bisschen, die Wissenschaft leichter zugänglich zu machen.
So einen Index zu bieten quasi. Auch so ein Go-To-Place anzubieten.
Ja. Gelbe Seiten für Datenbanken.
Ja genau. Ich wollte jetzt nicht Wikipedia sagen, aber man hat ja, ich denke, jetzt einfach nur weil das ja hier sozusagen eine kuratorische Leistung ist, sich a) erst mal die Kontexte zu ersinnen. Also was sind überhaupt die Bereiche, in denen man Daten haben will plus eben, was gibt es denn da für Studien und welche davon sind jetzt wirklich relevant. Das ist ja eigentlich Research. Da braucht man dann einen Research Officer wahrscheinlich. Und das dann halt auch in den Kontext zu stellen und dann eben auch mit anderen Kategorien zu kombinieren. Also die Daten zu nehmen und in einen neuen Bezug zu stellen. Also es ist einfach alles so eine Mehrwertkette, die an der Stelle losgetreten wird, die durch diesen digitalen offenen Umgang ja überhaupt erst ermöglicht wird.
Ich denke wir sind da echt tatsächlich erst am Anfang. Ich meine so ein bisschen einen Einblick hat man auch oft, weil die Naturwissenschaften den Sozialwissenschaften immer ein bisschen voraus sind in der Nutzung von technischen Möglichkeiten und zum Beispiel in der Astronomie  gibt es große bekannte Beispiele, wo der Link zwischen Wissenschaft und Webpublikation oft sehr stark ist und tatsächlich sehr gute Arbeit gemacht wird. Und in der Sozialwissenschaft stehen wir da wahrscheinlich erst am Anfang. Hoffe ich, dass es da noch ein bisschen in die Richtung weitergeht. Es ist ein großes Problem auch. Ein anderer Aspekt ist auch, was du vorhin angesprochen hast, mit der Datenverfügbarkeit, ist die Überprüfbarkeit von wissenschaftlichen Studien. Die Verfügbarmachung von empirischer Evidenz und Laien macht es es sehr viel einfacher, zu prüfen, was die Forschungskollegen tatsächlich gefunden haben.
Man kann Daten leichter austauschen gegen andere Daten und schauen, ob die Ergebnisse auch robust sind, wenn andere respektable Daten verwendet werden und mehr Forschung übers Internet zu verbreiten und das Internet auch als Quelle zu nutzen. Ich denke das kann der Forschung nur nutzen.
Wie viel Aufmerksamkeit, also ich meine man hat immer so den Eindruck, dass viel Arbeit, die gemacht wird, viele Studien im wissenschaftlichen Bereich dann irgendwie dort auch verbleiben und eigentlich gar nicht so richtig den Weg in die Öffentlichkeit finden. Ist das irgendwie?
Ja das stimmt. Ich denke das ist extrem schade. Weil die Arbeit ist oft wirklich faszinierende Arbeit und ist auch Arbeit, die die Öffentlichkeit kennen sollte, weil es die Leute informieren sollte, welche Politik sie wählen, welche Sicht sie einfach auf die Welt haben und die Forschung sollte der Öffentlichkeit leichter zur Verfügung stellen und es ist tatsächlich schade, dass sie dann in einem obskuren Journal veröffentlicht wird, das der Öffentlichkeit einfach nicht bekannt ist oder die Kommunikation nicht so sehr sucht. Das ist auch das Problem, dass die Anreize in der Wissenschaft nicht unbedingt da sind, die empirische Forschung nach außen zu tragen. Die Anreize sind sehr stark auf der Publikation, aber weniger stark auf der Kommunikation der Forschung.
Lässt sich das überhaupt messen, wie sehr Studien sozusagen ...?
Sicher. Da gibt es natürlich Arbeit dazu. Ein Beispiel vom letzten Jahr war, dass die Weltbank hingegangen ist und sie ihre eigenen Publikationen untersucht hat und deren Forschungsergebnis war, dass ein Drittel der Weltbankstudien niemals downgeloaded werden, niemals heruntergeladen werden.
Und das ist das primäre Outlet.
Die heißen Worldbank Policy Reports und sind wichtige Arbeiten und anscheinend ein Drittel davon kriegt keiner jemals zu Gesicht.
Interessiert sich einfach keiner.
Und es sollte die Leute interessieren. Ich denke nicht, dass es daran liegt, dass die Forschung schlecht ist. Ich denke, das liegt zum Großteil daran, dass die Kommunikation nicht gesucht wird.
Weil man sozusagen einfach, ja hier haben wir jetzt die Studie, Arbeit ist fertig, liegt online, fertig, Arbeit ist getan. Und dass man sozusagen nicht wahrnimmt, dass die Kommunikation …
Dann erst anfängt.
... dann eigentlich erst anfängt, genau.
Ja.
Du hast ja im Prinzip mit dem our world in data, jetzt abgesehen von der Webseite, weiß nicht, hat so den Eindruck, so Twitter scheint ein relativ wichtiges Instrument gewesen zu sein für das Projekt, kann man das so sagen? Was so Aufmerksamkeitsgenerierung betrifft?
Auf jeden Fall. Das ist auch eine Sache, die mich überrascht hat, dass das so gut funktioniert hat mit Twitter und Social-Media.
Was ist denn da passiert?
Ich war immer so ein Twitteruser, ich hatte einen Account und hab da weiß nicht jeden Monat mal reingeschaut, um zu schauen, was so ein paar Leute tun und lesen, die mich interessieren. Und erst vor einem Jahr habe ich es angefangen, ein bisschen zu nutzen, um meine Arbeit darüber zu kommunizieren.
Vor einem Jahr?
Ja. Nicht mal, vielleicht im November oder irgendsowas.
Ich zähle hier 31.475 Follower, das ist für ein Jahr eine ganz gute Quote im Jahre 2015.
Ja die Kommunikation darüber funktioniert irgendwie ganz gut. Ich denke mein einer Punkt ist, dass ich immer diese Visualisierung, die ich mache, über Twitter teile und dass die einfach ein bisschen rausstehen aus dem Twitter-Feed, wenn du da drauf schaust und das meiste ist Text und dann hast du eine Grafik und dann scheint es die Leute zu interessieren.
Das Bild mal wieder mehr als 14 Worte.
Ich weiß es nicht, woran es liegt, aber es funktioniert auf jeden Fall gut, und das ist wirklich eine gute Möglichkeit auch denke ich insgesamt für Wissenschaftler. Ich versuche auch, alle meine Kollegen hier sind jetzt auch Teil von der Diskussion auf Social-Media und nutzen das auch. Weil es einfach gut funktioniert, um mit den Menschen, die ähnliche Arbeit machen, in Kontakt zu kommen und seine Arbeit zu kommunizieren letztlich ja.
Es gibt ja auch noch ein paar andere Wissenschaftler, die so in letzter Zeit auffällig geworden sind durch interessante Weltbetrachtung. Also mir würde jetzt so Hans Rossling zum Beispiel einfallen. Erinnere ich das gerade richtig?
Ja sicher. Ich meine, Hans Rosslings Arbeit war sicher eine von den Inspirationen auch für meine Arbeit und ich denke der hat großartige Arbeit gemacht mit Gapminder.
Kannst du das mal kurz zusammenfassen, was er gemacht hat?
Hans Rossling ist eigentlich ein Arzt aus Schweden, der lange in Afrika, vor allem in Mosambik gearbeitet hat und dann war er Professor für Global Health am Karolinska-Institut in Stockholm. Und jetzt hat er über die letzten 15-20 Jahre sehr viel Arbeit gemacht, indem er versucht so demografische Trends, Bevölkerungswachstum, Geburtenraten und Gesundheitstrends, Lebenserwartung, Kindersterblichkeit, HIV zu kommunizieren, und hat vor allen Dingen ein paar große Ted-Talks gehalten in den USA, die sehr bekannt geworden sind und versucht, so ein globales Bild von demografischen und Gesundheitsentwicklungen auf der Welt darzustellen. Und jetzt er war grade letzte Woche hier und wir machen jetzt auch ein bisschen Arbeit zusammen.
Im Moment machen wir eine Dokumentation, die im September auf der BBC läuft, zu globaler Armut. Und da ist das das zentrale Thema. Da sind die Daten und die Arbeit von our world in data und Gabminder seine Stiftung in Stockholm lizenziert das und er präsentiert es dann in einer Dokumentation.
Also Daten sind auf einmal sexy. Also früher waren so die Zahlenwerke waren einfach langweilig. Wer setzt sich schon davor und spielt den Numbercruncher. Und durch die Visualisierung und ich würde halt auch sagen, durch die einfache Möglichkeit, zu publizieren und wahrscheinlich auch interaktiv das Ganze anzubieten, spielt das eine große Rolle? Weiß nicht so vom Feedback her? Also geht es nur darum, überhaupt Zahlen und Auswertungen zu haben oder ist die interaktive Komponente wichtig oder ist das nur so ein Beiwerk? Schwer zu sagen.
Bissen schwer zu sagen denke ich. Ich meine, es ist sicher ein großer Unterschied zu den Zahlenwerken, die tatsächlich nur Tabellen beinhalten. Das gibt es ja auch leider häufig, dass eine Institution meint, sie ist mit der Arbeit fertig, sobald sie irgendwo eine Excel-Datei auf irgendeinen Server gelegt hat, in dem die Daten verfügbar sind. Vom Excel-File bis zur Datenvisualisierung das ist oft der entscheidende Schritt, um es attraktiv zu machen. Wie viel die Interaktivität, wie wichtig das den Leuten ist, das weiß ich eigentlich nicht so richtig.
Aber die eigentliche Kraft liegt sozusagen darin, auch zu finden, was macht man mit den Zahlen? Also auf welchen Aspekt schaut man. Wie visualisiert man etwas? Ist es jetzt hier wichtiger mit irgendwie Tortengrafiken zu arbeiten oder mit Balken. Ja man kann ja, es gibt ja auch diesen schönen, sicherlich wahren Satz so, glaube keiner Statistik, die du nicht selbst gefälscht hast, wenn wir das mal hier übertragen, man kann die Bedeutung von Zahlen eigentlich erst in dem Moment erfassen, wo man auch den richtigen Aspekt sich angeschaut hat und eben das vielleicht auch auf die richtige Art und Weise gemacht hat.
Das stimmt. Und denke ich auch, deshalb wäre es auch wichtig, das mehr in den Schulen zu verankern. Ich denke das ist wirklich ein Punkt, der fehlt. Ich hatte ein extrem guten Geschichte Lehrer, ich war super glücklich mit dem Fach und habe mich dafür interessiert. Aber wir haben uns nie diese Sachen, nie so einen quantitativen Blick auf die Geschichte angeschaut im Geschichtsunterricht. Und ich denke, heute wo Daten so omnipräsent sind, ist es auch wichtig, Kindern und jedem beizubringen, was die Grenzen von der Belastbarkeit von diesen Daten sind und wie leicht es auch ist, Daten auch so darzustellen, um eine bestimmte Message damit zu verbreiten und so eine Art …
Eine kritische Auseinandersetzung mit Zahlen auch zu fördern?
Ja und auch mit der grafischen Darstellung von Zahlen. Ich weiß nicht, wo das zu Hause wäre, wahrscheinlich irgendwo zwischen Mathe und Geschichtsunterricht.
Ja, vielleicht gut Geschichte ist sagen wir mal ein Anwendungsfall, aber ich finde, das ist sicherlich auch etwas, was Mathematik neues Leben einhauchen kann. Weil ja viele Leute auch immer so ein bisschen angeödet sind und irgendwie nicht verstehen, warum jetzt irgendwie das Erarbeiten von so einer Zahl jetzt so wertvoll sein soll für das eigene Leben. Aber in dem Moment, wo man irgendwie Ergebnisse erzielt, kriegt das auf einmal eine ganz andere Bedeutung. Also ich weiß auch noch, ich habe irgendwann mal im Mathematikunterricht irgendwie so eine Wurfkurve irgendwie mit dem Computer visualisiert und das war dann so für alle so, oh Gott was so was geht? Und auf einmal hatte die Parabel, die vorher einfach so ein Detail aus so einem Mathebuch war, hatte auf einmal so einen ganz realen richtigen Bezug und man konnte sich das irgendwie anschauen und das machte irgendwie auf einmal alles Sinn.
Falls ein Mathelehrer uns da zuhört, dann er kann die ganzen Daten auf der Webseite herunterladen und kann morgen sich hinsetzen und die mit seinen Schülern in Diagramme verwandeln. Vielleicht bei den Statistikkursen.
Wie war es denn im Studium? Ich meine jetzt drei verschiedene Studiengänge, die du gemacht hast, gab es da schon irgendwie so eine Inspiration vielleicht in die Richtung? Gerade bei der Ökonomie?
Nein in der Ökonomie haben wir sehr viel Theorie gemacht und dann statistische Analyse gemacht, aber Visualisierung haben wir nie wirklich zu einem Thema gemacht dort in dem Studium tatsächlich. Ja es fehlt ein bisschen in der Ausbildung vielleicht ja. Ich meine, ein Problem ist auch, dass die Werkzeuge, mit denen man solche Visualisierungen machen kann, vielleicht nicht immer so ganz leicht zugänglich sind. Es gibt natürlich Excel, das ist wahrscheinlich das, was die meisten Leute auf ihrem Computer haben, aber es ist schon ein bisschen limitiert in dem, was es an Datenvisualisierung ermöglicht. Und dann wenn man Daten online interaktiv visualisieren mag, dann verwenden die meisten Bibliotheken in JavaScript und dann wird es gleich ein bisschen komplizierter und nicht so ganz leicht zugänglich. Und wenn man Daten mit Software visualisieren mag auf dem Computer, dann gibt es extrem gute Software.
Zum Beispiel eine große Software ist Tableau, aber da kostet die Lizenz dann 1.500 Euro oder so. Vielleicht fehlt auch ein bisschen die, oder ich weiß es nicht, die OpenSource-Lösung, die für jeden zugänglich ist.
Naja ich finde ja, ich meine die Plots und die Auswertungen, die jetzt bei our world in data sind, die sind ja jetzt nicht bestechend dadurch, dass sie jetzt besondere Komplexität hätten, sondern es ist eigentlich eher die einfache Darstellung sozusagen, das richtige Herauswählen der richtigen Daten und das in Kontext stellen miteinander, was glaube ich hier eine Rolle spielt. Also was ich da so rausziehe ist, also ich finde wissenschaftliche Arbeiten auf einmal spannend, wenn ich die Möglichkeit habe, mir diese Ergebnisse einfach leichter vorzustellen. Und da hilft nun mal einfach so eine Grafik enorm. Und was ich natürlich auch hier sehe bei dem Projekt, dass man einfach die Kollaboration auch anheizt. Also in dem Moment, wo man ... ich meine es mag jetzt jemanden geben, der ist halt sehr gut darin, die Daten zu gewinnen. Das ist so ein bisschen so der Miner sozusagen. In der Datenmine wird halt überhaupt erst mal so das Datenerz zusammengesammelt und es gibt halt Leute, die sich darauf spezialisieren, aber deren Ding vielleicht diese Visualisierung erst mal gar nicht ist.
Die einem einfach sagen, okay hier sind jetzt die Daten. Dann kommen die nächsten Leute, die sagen, okay, wir bringen das jetzt hier mal in einen Kontext und versuchen mal, die Richness, also sozusagen das was in diesen Daten drinliegt auch durch eine ordentliche Visualisierung herauszuheben. Das würde ich jetzt mal sagen ist das, was eigentlich our world in data primär macht. Und der nächste Schritt ist halt, dass man die Daten dann quasi auch wieder bereitstellt und so eine Challenge eigentlich daraus macht und sagt, okay hier sind die Daten, das war der First Take, was könnt ihr jetzt damit machen? Was sind die anderen Sachen, mit denen man das noch korrelieren kann. Bis hin zu, welche Standards lassen sich vielleicht aus solchen Prozessen ableiten?
Und das funktioniert auch. Das sehe ich auch dann, Leute laden die Daten dort von meiner Publikation runter und dann machen sie ihre eigene Arbeit damit und dann schicken es mir manchmal per E-Mail oder per Twitter und teilen es wieder zurück. Das ist auch extrem cool, zu sehen, dass diese Zusammenarbeit so funktioniert. Und insgesamt ist es ein bisschen verrückt, dass wir nicht mehr zusammenarbeiten in der Sozialwissenschaft, nicht nur in der Ökonomie ... der Großteil von den Veröffentlichungen haben einen Autor, zwei, ab und zu mal vielleicht drei Autoren. Das heißt, dass dieser eine Autor, in den meisten Fällen ist es immer noch ein Autor, tatsächlich alles macht, von der Datenbeschaffung, manchmal wenn es Primärdatenerhebung ist, dann reist er nach Afrika und macht dort die Studien, dann ist er der, der die Daten weiterverwendet in der statistischen Software. Und die Daten sauber macht und die Daten visualisiert und die Analyse schreibt und die Theorie dazu schreibt und den Literaturüberblick schreibt.
Und das ist alles ein und dieselbe Person. Die Ökonomen, in den Vorlesungen reden wir den ganzen Tag davon, wie wichtig nicht die Arbeitsteilung für die Produktivität ist und dann setzen wir uns an unseren Arbeitstisch und schreiben unser Paper ganz alleine von Anfang bis Ende. Und ich denke, wir könnten viel viel bessere Arbeit machen, wenn wir mehr Arbeit in kleineren Schritten teilen würden mit Kollegen und mehr Zusammenarbeit mit anderen Experten in verschiedenen Tätigkeiten suchen würden.
Und vielleicht so ähnlich, wie das bei den Datenjournalisten ist, dass ich quasi so auch neue also Berufsbilder oder Forschungsbilder ... wie soll man denn das nennen? Berufsbild, Berufsforschungsbilder. Also so eine andere Klasse von wissenschaftlicher Arbeit auf einmal hervorkommt, wo es nicht primär darum geht, ich bin jetzt in diesem Bereich Experte, Expertin für irgendwas, sondern ich bin einfach in der Lage, wissenschaftliche Daten an sich vollkommen unabhängig davon, in welchem Bereich sich das jetzt bewegt, in Korrelation zu setzen. Dass man sich sozusagen jemanden ins Boot holt, der oder die einfach da in der Lage ist, aus den Ergebnissen, die man gesammelt hat, mehr zu machen und auch sagen wir mal darin spezialisiert ist, sie anderen zugänglich zu machen.
Ja ich glaube auch, dass die Naturwissenschaften da wieder einen Schritt vorne sind und so in der medizinischen biologischen Forschung gibt es tatsächlich Leute, die sich darauf spezialisieren, die Grafiken gut darzustellen. Vielleicht nicht nur die Visualisierung von Daten, sondern auch diese Abbildung von Zellen und den Abläufen von irgendeinem Prozess im Körper, der dann in solchen schematischen Darstellungen in den Publikationen sich dort findet. Dort gibt es das. Aber die Kollaboration sollte irgendwie kleiner sein. Und das liegt auch wieder, da waren wir vorhin schon mal bei dem Thema, dass es an den Anreizen liegt. Heute sind die Anreize sehr stark dafür da, für die fertige Publikation und nicht so sehr für Schritte, die zu der Publikation führen. Wenn du der bist, der die Daten sauber gemacht hat und standardisiert hast oder so was, und damit drei Monate von deinem Leben verbracht hast.
Dann kriegst du dafür keine Anerkennung, obwohl das ein zentraler Teil von der Arbeit war, wenn du der warst, der die Daten visualisiert hast, dann kriegst du dafür keine Anerkennung, die kriegst du nur, wenn du alles von Anfang an bis Ende gemacht hast.
Obwohl das eigentlich gar nicht so sinnvoll ist.
Und das ist auch ein Teil, was ich jetzt gesehen habe. In den letzten Jahren war ich jetzt, weil ich die Publikation im Internet geschrieben habe, war ich natürlich viel mehr in dieser OpenSource-Landschaft unterwegs und habe gesehen, wie dort Kollaboration funktioniert und das ist für jemanden, der in der Wissenschaft ist, wo jeder versucht, seine kleine Nische zu verteidigen, atemberaubend zu sehen, wie freizügig dort Teile von Programmen geteilt werden. Wie Leute bei anderen Projekten mitarbeiten und dazu beitragen. Das ist vielleicht was man von dieser Arbeit lernen könnte für die Wissenschaft selbst.
Ja das Ding mit der Suppe. Wenn jeder so sein Ding mit in den Topf reinschmeißt, dann haben halt alle am Ende eine wohlschmeckende Suppe, die die einzelnen Komponenten so eben nicht gebracht hätte.
Genau ja. Mehr Suppe kochen.
Mehr Suppe kochen. Max Roser, ich sage vielen dank für den schönen Einblick hier in eine, ich würde mal sagen, eine durchaus zukunftsträchtige Art und Weise, wissenschaftliche Arbeit zu verstehen und neu zu definieren, indem man einfach hier auch bewusst die Möglichkeiten der Netz- und Computertechnologie bewusst nutzt, aber auch wo sich andere Ansätze denke ich finden lassen, wie Kollaboration aussehen kann, aussehen sollte und wie man damit eben sozusagen die wissenschaftliche Arbeit auch an sich versteht. Danke.
Danke dir Tim.
Und vielen Dank natürlich wieder auch an alle, die hier fleißig zuhören bei Forschergeist. Ich sage tschüss und bis bald bis zum nächsten Mal.